一切が変わったんだから
自信がない心とは それから現在という問題を説明します
心は漏電している したがって機能しない
現在も我々の心はずっと漏電
ほとんど漏電ばっかしでエネルギーはないんですよ
だから機械繋げても動かない
自信という高慢が自信をなくす
これ自信があるということは高慢ですよ
これが自信をなくすんですよ
慢 自分のことを高く評価する
慢というのは 一般的には自分をすごく高くでもどちらでも評価するんですね
大事なものやと低く評価する
あるいは あるいは社会の評価に依存する
自分の立場をはっきりするために
社会はどう考えてくれるのかとかね
社会のことを気にする
それはどちらでも慢ですよ
仏教から見れば または外ばかりを見て
自分のことをよく知らないということになりますね
自分が安全だと感じる慢
よく言いますよ あの人はこうです
あの人はこうです この人もこうですとかね
社会の外ばっか見ているんですよ
ああいう風になればいい
こういう風になればいいとか
あの人のようにやりたい
この人のようにやりたいとかね
外ばっかし見るんだけど
自分のことを見ないんです
なんで見ないのかというと
自分には何でもできると
自分に対しては安全感
例えば どなたかすごく美しく歌っちゃうと
じゃあ私もそういう風に歌わなくちゃと自分にできるかないか
それは気にしないんです
できるだと思っているんですね
これも慢で こんなことでも自信がなくなっちゃいますよ
歌ってみたらみんなブーイングするんだから
自信がなくなっちゃうんです
だからそれ この4項目で書いたのは
この慢というものが我々のどういう
こういう風に現れるんだということなんです
これは現在なんですけど
自信がなくなる これが心に入ると強烈な抵抗力なんですよ
こういう慢というものは
心に入り込んじゃうと
これがすごい抵抗力になっちゃって
体がストップさせるんですね
体も心も 自信を壊す他の害虫もいます
一番大きい問題は慢ということです
で 覚えておいてください
またいろいろ害虫がいるんです
抵抗力はいろいろあるんです
このアビッジャという
言葉ありますね それは異常な欲ですね
仏教を皆様ご存知だと思いますけど
一応欲は 2つに分けてます
一つは普通の常識的な欲
可愛い女の子が好きとかね
美味しいものを食べたいとかね
ちょっと金がなければもう家族はちょっと大変だとかね
もっとかっこいい服を着たいとかね
まあそういうふうな日常生活の中の欲がありますね
音楽を聞いたりとかね
今日は休みだから遊びに行きたいとかね
それも欲なんですけど
異常じゃないんです 異常という欲もあるんですよ
特にこの欲で犯罪を起こしちゃうのは
この異常な欲なんですね
頭の中で それでただ遊びにアビッジャって何なのかと今日考えたんですけど
アビっていうのはちょっと異常って不自然
ちょっと乗り越えているというね
スーパーという意味なんですね
英語で言えばアブノーマル
スーパーということ イッチャーという単語とイッジャティという単語っていうのは
期待するというエクスペクテーションということなんですね
だからスーパー的なことを期待する
仕事をすれば まあ次々
まあせいぜい 30万ぐらい収入あるかもしれませんだけど
すぐ 100万のお給料を期待しちゃうとアビッジャなんですね
その能力も経験もないわりに
だから サラリーマンは億万長者のリストに入ったと大いに宣伝しちゃうと
他のサラリーマンの方々も
もう私もそうなればありがたいなと思ったりして
もう骨が折れると思いますけど
あんなのは一般論として日本放送してはいけない
あれはもう稀な稀な稀なケースなんですよ
サラリーマンでもう何でしたっけ？あれは農政の長者ね
長者番付に入ったっていうのは
あれはもう もうサラリーマンではね
あれはもう徹底的に特別なケースで
で まあ時々テレビでね
みんなの豪邸を紹介したりとかね
いろいろやって この人間のアビッジャーをとにかく火をつけてあげようと
と頑張ってるんです 人間のその煩悩があるんだから
まあもうよだれ垂らしながらそういう番組を見る
とても危険だと思います
態度は良くない まあなんだ
だから だから何をという態度でね
一回見たんですけど 香港でなんかある金持ちが自分の車のナンバープレートも金で作ってあって
それで中国ではこの番号にも迷信的な信仰がありますから
このこの決まってる八とかね
そういう番号だけ自分がすごい高いお金で買って
それで家に入るゲートにも結構金で
もう一番面白かったのは便所の座るあれありますね
あの便座 あれ金なんです
だからだから何をと プラスチックの方が冷たくはないのに
あれ冷たいでしょ だからそういうものを放映して
人々のアビッジャーを扇ぎ
煽り立てようという風にしちゃうんですよ
これっていうのは精神的な病気です
明らかに 美味しいご飯食べたいなっていうのは
それは病気じゃないんです
ただの欲です それでも苦労しているのに
家族のこと好きなんですけど
それは欲なんですよ 別に病気じゃないんですよ
でもそれで結構苦労してるでしょうに
なのに それを上でこの病気になっちゃうと
もう大変です この欲は決して現実にならないものです
だからアビッジャーという欲は決して現実化することはできない
単なる妄想で終わっちゃうんですね
普通の欲ならいくらでも現実できますけどね
普通の欲だったらちょこっと頑張ればね
そんなに夢の話じゃないんですよ
アビッジャーはもうできません
夢の話 叶わぬ夢ばかりを頭を独占しているから
動くはずはありません
それで頭の中で叶わぬ夢をね
ずっと動くんだから もう体動かないんですよ
この仕事ちょっとできます
けれど これやったらもう 5,000円しかもらえませんので
まあいいやと言うんですよ
頭の中で 1,000万円のことあるんだからね
やらないんです 自信がなくなるんですよ
ウェーパーダっていうのは
前と同じく怒りなんですね
欲があれば怒りも病気もあります
それは分析してないんですけど
ヴィッっていう のはおかしい
変ということで またアブノーマルという意味なんです
アーパダっていうのは
この害を与えたい 攻撃したいという気持ちなんで
これはちょっとおかしい異常
だからごく普通に喧嘩とは違いますよ
夫婦喧嘩と兄弟喧嘩と仲間でいろいろ喧嘩することとは
それとは違います これはある一種の病気
おかしい この怒りはという
この怒りは内向きになって自己破壊的になるんですよ
だから別に相手がないんですよ
内向きに怒りが回転するんですよ
根拠なく人がうるさいんだからこの野郎って言っちゃうと
これは外向きなんですよ
うるさいんだよという場合はね
そこではっきり具体的な怒りだから
解決方法もあります ただ単にもう音はうるさいやと怒ると
これは危ないんですよ
突然人は誰でもいいんだから殺したかったとかね
とにかく何人か殺したかったとかいう犯罪あるでしょうね
それで一人勝手に引っ込んで
いろんなもうサイバー世界で生きていて
どんどん怒りを増やす
本当はもう対象はない
自分自身なんですね それでもうたまらなくなっちゃうと
外へ出て何人かを殺しちゃう
人の関係もない 知らない人の家に火をつけたりとかね
相手は誰でもいいんです
だから普通だったら もうもう敵がいて
ライバルがいて あるいは喧嘩になって人を殺したっていう場合は
そこは状況はよく理解できます
この理解できない犯罪やらある場合は
この怒りなんですね そこでその怒りでゴーゴーゴーゴーと心の中で回転すると
ものすごくもうエネルギーがなくなるんです
外の世界について興味さえなくなりますよ
仕事をできるところか
自信のところか 興味さえもなくなっちゃうんです
審議の人は自信がないだけで終わらないで
引きこもり状態にも陥るんですね
ん？それからこの的が外れるということ
それも時間の問題で 時間のズレがない場合は機会を失うという現象も起こります
時々これ ちょっと難しいんですよ
時間のズレって私が言ったのは特別な用語で
過去のことを妄想する
将来のことを妄想する
それが私は時間のズレという
もうタイムラグというタイムラグなんですけど
そういうふうな単語を使ったんです
単語で覚えてください
時間ズレがなかったら現在にいるんですよ
現在にいるんだけど チャンスを逃しちゃうんですね
機会を そのポイントを説明したいんです
目の前にある仕事を理解できなくなる
後回しにすることですよ
で 何か仕事 これは理解できないし
後でできるんだと 明日やるんだとかね
後回しにする これ 今やらなくちゃいけないことは後できないんですよ
後では別なことをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
今お腹が空いてるんだったら
今ご飯食べなくちゃいけないでしょうに
じゃあ明日食べますよと
延期しちゃうと 明日食べても今食べるチャンスがもう逃しちゃったんですよ
逃しちゃったんです だからそこをすごく気をつけてほしいんですよ
私は 私たちはいろんな仕事を後に後に回しますけど
そう簡単に仕事を後に回すんじゃなくて
本当に後に回してもよろしいかと
例えば土曜日 もう来週土曜日
子供はどこか遠足に行くならば
その準備は金曜日の夜にするそうと聞いたところで
それが後回しじゃないんですよ
今日月曜日なのに じゃあ弁当作ってあげようとかね
今月曜弁当を作ったって
もう子供は遠足に行くのはもう土曜日だから
それは意味がないんですよ
その場合は 土曜日の朝
子供が出欠した時には
必要なものは用意してあげなくちゃいけない
母親が それは金曜日か土曜日
朝やればいいんです それは後回しではありません
子供が勉強する気になっちゃって
お母さんこれ教えてくださいと言ったところで
今忙しいんだから もう夜やりますと
言うと 夜は子供は勉強する気持ちはまるっきりないかもしれません
そうすると喧嘩になる可能性あります
あるいは正しい結果が出ない可能性もあります
だから後回しっていうのは
そういうところで 今やるべきことを後回しにしてはいけないんですね
しちゃう そのチャンスは二度と来ないんですよ
えーと 次なんですね 原因は
なんで我々は後回しにするのかというと
落ち着きがない あるいは怠け
あるいは興味が薄い まああまり興味がない
まあ後でしますとか 理解するべきという大事なことはしない
これはわからないかもしれませんよ
これ 仏教の立場なんですね
何する 何をしても それって何やとよく理解しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ただやっただけでは意味がないんですよ
私によく見えることは
みんなこのロボットみたいにいろんなことをするんですね
全然その なんであんたこれやるのかと聞いたってわからないんですね
挨拶やら礼儀作法やらあれこれ全てマンネリになっちゃって
もうただ機械でやっているような感じで
これでは知恵っていうのはもう全く現れない
特に日本ではもう何でも早くも早くも決まりにするんですね
習慣にするんですね それで良い習慣ならいいんだけど
明らかにくだらないものだったら必ず習慣にする
それっていうのはもうずっと無知でいられるための仕事なんですね
その方が楽やと だから仏教は認めないんですよ
どんな小さなことをしたっても
なんとか理性 理解があってほしいんです
どんな小さなことをする時でも
ちょこっとしたゴミをゴミ箱に入れる時でも
いつでもやっぱり頭は動かした方がいいんですよ
こういう風に捨てるそうとかね
これはそのまま捨てるんじゃなくて
もうちょこっと畳んで捨てるそうとかね
あるいは潰して捨てるそうとかね
このちょっとしたことがものすごく必要なんです
それで人生楽しくなるんですよ
だからこれ無知っていうこと
これは自分の国のお寺なんですけど
向こうは絨毯とかそういうことはないんだから
いつでも箒で床を拭いておかなきゃいけないんですね
箒っていうのは このココナッツのあれでできたもので
このブラシみたいな すごい柔らかいんですよ
で あの毛がすごい 長いブラシと思っちゃえばね
日本の箒とは違います
南アフリカはすごく硬いんですけどね
あれで綺麗に埃まで何でも拭くことはできます
で みんなあの箒をそうただ立てておくんですね
あれは怠けでも そのままどこかに
壁のどこかにもすぐそのまま立てておくんです
立てておいて 下はこの箒の毛の方なんですよ
上のあれが重いんだから全部曲がっちゃうんですね
そうすると大体まあ二
三週間になってくると
全部箒の毛が全部曲がっちゃって
もう綺麗に拭けなくなっちゃうんです
で また新しいものを買わなくちゃいけない
それで私はこれ理解するだろうと思って
いつでも私は箒使うと横にしておくんですね
立てるんじゃなくて その方がたくさんの箒を畳めますよ
ベッドの下とかどこでも
どうせ家の中のものだから外は出せません
立てておくこともそんな何本も立てておけませんし
場所も取れるし でも私はいくら体でこういうやり方でやってもやっても
一度でも理解はしない
取った部屋はきちんと拭いた
そのままどこかに立てておく
ああ なるほどと 言わない
私はごちゃごちゃごちゃあれこれやと言って理解したっても
何の面白いことも何でもない
それは人間として成長はしない
ちょこっと微妙に考えて
それをやると それはその人の成長につながるんですよ
そういうことっていうのは
嫌になるほど日本の社会でも見られます
ただマンネリでいろんなことをやるだけで
それでは良くないんですよ
いつでもこうだからこうするんだよという
ことが必要なんです それも大胆ではなくて
ちょっ小さなところからね
例えば皿を洗う場合は
こういう こういう風に洗った方がいいだと
そこと考えると いつでもこの短い時間で
短い労働力でたくさん仕事できるようになるんです
それで ものすごく知恵が出てきますよ
ものすごい元気になります
その人は決してどんな仕事でもやるんです
できます 自信があるかないかでなくて
やっちゃいます ただ理性があるんだから
だから この物事を理解するべきということはものすごい大事なんです
例えば この格好をどこかに置いてくださいと言ったら
はい わかりました ポーンと置く
それではもう人間らしからん
そういうちっちゃなことの中でも
何か理解するということはあるんです
こんな微妙なものにしても
それでなんで私はそこはそんなに気にするのかというと
この人の性格はこの人が無意識的にやることで読めるんです
みんなキャムフラージュしているんだから
すごいいい格好をつけようと思っているんですけど
もうむちゃくちゃ見えるんですよ
この無意識的にいろんなことをやってますから
性格は だからそれが我々には必要なんですよ
この人はどうやってアドバイスして
どうやって助けてあげなくちゃいけないかということをしなくちゃいかんから
それで嫌なことばっかり見えるんだからね
本当にもう私はかなり悪業しているでしょうかね
覚醒で 以上の状況なら
心は重すぎ そういうね
怒りやら欲やら怠けやらね
やる気がない 興味がない
そういうものがあると心は重いんですよ
心の中の整理整頓は全くない
頭の中は綺麗に 頭の中は整理整頓しておかなくちゃいけないんですよ
これがなくなるんですよ
エンジンがかからない状態ですね
そうすると それで仏教用語がありますよ
みんな知ってるんだから
ただ言葉だけ並べておきたんです
上工という これ混乱状態のユタンゴで
これからもう何でしたっけ？怠惰
怠惰 これ怠けですね 放逸
それは仏教専門用語で
それを全部まとめて放逸とも言いますけどね
アップマートというの貪瞋ですね
貪瞋でやる気がなくて
なんかもうもうもう寝たい状態でだるさなんですね
無知 それから疑い ピチギッチャーというんですね
そういうもので自信がなくなるんです
理解せず 必要かどうかは気にせず
やればいいという気持ちを優先すると
無知が心の管理者になるのです
やればいいと理解もしないし
こんなことやってやることは必要じゃないかと
それも考えませんし ただやればいいんじゃないかといって
マンネリになって ロボットみたいに生きている人々の場合は
人生は無知に管理しているんです
いつでも頭がなんとなく回転していないととっても危険なんです
それは